Bienvenidos a esta nueva edición del
programa enlace cono Sur desde la ciudad
de Río de Janeiro en el que hablaremos
de la disminución de la violencia en el
país Tropical donde el año pasado se
registraron
40.800 asesinatos una cifra alta pero
mucho más baja que hace tan solo 6 años
en 2017 la media anual era de 59 mil
homicidios son datos del foro brasileño
de seguridad pública Durante los cuatro
años de mandato de Jair bolsonaro se
produjo una baja del 30%. el
expresidente de Brasil atribuye este
fenómeno al hecho de que la población
está más Armada el número de homicidios
por arma de fuego cayó hasta su nivel
histórico más bajo la prensa no cuenta
que entre otras cosas la liberación de
las armas para gente del bien hace que
las personas se lo piensen dos veces
antes de cometer una estupidez sin
embargo la mayoría de los expertos en
seguridad pública de Brasil no están de
acuerdo con esta lectura y ofrecen otras
explicaciones Daniel cerquera es el
coordinador del atlas de la violencia y
una de las personas que más sabe de este
tema en Brasil Me gustaría saber cómo
explicamos esta bajada de las muertes
violentas en Brasil existen varias
razones en las últimas décadas la
cantidad de la proporción de jóvenes en
la población de forma acentuada esta
disminución tendría el potencial de
hacer disminuir los homicidios en un 20%
el segundo factor es el armisticio entre
las dos grandes facciones del
narcotráfico que entre 2017 y 2018
libraron una guerra Sangrienta en las
presiones brasileñas yo te acerco el
tercer punto tiene que ver con un cambio
cualitativo en las políticas de
seguridad pública en Brasil a partir
sobre todo de 2010 las políticas están
basadas en evidencias científicas en la
planificación el diagnóstico y
precisamente en los estados que
implementaron ese tipo de políticas es
donde vemos la mayor reducción está
bajada solo no fue más grande porque
Lamentablemente tuvimos esta legislación
irresponsable de armas de fuego para
todos si no fuese por esta política al
menos seis mil cuatrocientas personas
estarían vivas hoy
más de un millón de armas entraron en
circulación durante la era bolsonaro el
gobierno de Lula ha lanzado una campaña
para registrar de nuevo las armas de los
coleccionistas cazadores y tiradores
deportivos esta fue la puerta por la que
muchos brasileños tuvieron acceso a
armas y municiones durante el mandato de
bolsonaro el gobierno de Luna intenta
reducir el número de armas ilegales en
circulación y al mismo tiempo evitar que
lleguen a manos de narcotraficantes y
delincuentes hasta la fecha se ha
conseguido regularizar el 99% de las
armas la proliferación descontrolada de
las armas es considerada una de las
principales causas para explicar este
aumento de la violencia en las escuelas
brasileñas en marzo de este año en esa
escuela mi espalda en Río de Janeiro un
alumno de 15 años atacó a sus colegas
con un cuchillo sin causar ninguna
muerte sin embargo datos oficiales
revelan que los últimos 20 años al menos
24 alumnos y dos profesores murieron de
forma violenta y matanzas que recuerdan
el día a día en los Estados Unidos y es
más en las últimas dos décadas hubo 23
ataques contra escuelas brasileñas según
un estudio de la Universidad de campinas
ante esta situación muchas escuelas en
diferentes puntos del país están
instalando detectores de metales
aquí en el estado de Río de Janeiro el
gobierno local acaba de lanzar un
programa de formación junto a la policía
militar para mejorar la gestión de los
riesgos en las escuelas
este entrenamiento está pensado para que
los profesionales de la educación sepan
Cómo actuar en Casos de conflicto de
crisis antes de la llegada de la policía
el objetivo final es ofrecer más
seguridad a alumnos y a profesores Esto
es lo que nos han contado los
responsables del curso que son
protocolos son protocolos que pretenden
orientar En caso de que acontezca algún
problema en estas escuelas por ejemplo
identificar en las escuelas vías de fuga
locales para protegerse e identificar
otras situaciones posibles para que
puedan tomar providencias hasta que las
fuerzas policiales lleguen a estos
centros escolares
nosotros queremos que los profesores
sepan Cuáles son las normas de conducta
en caso de violencia de manera alguna
queremos que ellos coloquen su vida en
riesgo queremos que ellos ayuden a
encontrar más rápidamente a aquellos que
van a salvar Y cuidar de nuestras vidas
en la actualidad El Congreso de Brasil
está analizando un proyecto de ley que
pretende moderar los contenidos
violentos en las redes sociales con el
objetivo de proteger a los menores los
ataques contra las escuelas están
motivados por adolescentes que quieren
salir del anonimato Y ser parte de la
historia de los crímenes célebres para
eso estos crímenes que cometen deben ser
famosos y para esto tienen que circular
las imágenes por eso las redes sociales
no deben dejar circular este tipo de
contenido específicamente estos
contenidos violentos ya están prohibidos
por los términos de uso de las grandes
empresas tecnológicas pero a pesar de
esto ellos no son moderados de una forma
muy efectiva principalmente porque una
moderación bien hecha cuesta bastante
dinero este proyecto basado en el modelo
europeo es criticado por los bolos
analistas que lo tildan de censura y por
las grandes empresas del sector
tecnológico que temen perder sus
ingresos publicitarios multimillonarios
sin embargo si Brasil consigue ese
aprobar esa ley se colocaría en la
vanguardia mundial de La regulación de
las redes sociales hasta aquí el enlace
cono Sur sobre la violencia en Brasil yo
soy Valeria sacona y la cámara mi colega
amiguidara Hasta pronto